So far we've seen how to get
the app shell into the cache.
But how do we get it out so that on
a slow network or even no network,
we're still able to get the resources
required to run our app.
For that we'll need to intercept
all the network requests
by handling the fetch event
in the service worker.
And serving the requested
resource from the cache.
Stepping from inside out
caches.match evaluates the request
that triggered the fetch, and checks
to see if it's available in the cache.
It then either responds
with the cached version, or
uses fetch to get a copy
from the network.
The response is then passed back
to the webpage with e.respondWith